welcome to the oven Carmichael show the
show yes this is neither hey hi so we've
been cleaning up I've been cleaning up
but we've been feeling that evening I've
been clean as a charity so I've been
cleaned up slowly as Dina says and I've
come across these sports cards or some
hockey cards and I didn't know how i
came across these ones and i took him to
the dealer door to the dealer and and he
said they basically not worth anything
which is very sad tears he wouldn't even
take them he wouldn't give me anything
for them nothing not even a dollar sorry
i struggled that I held on to them I
wasn't sure what to do with them because
it already just thrown away I feel like
somebody could benefit from them you
know this dump Gilmore leaf nation Doug
healing one on the front anyway so I
didn't know what to do with them and it
would kind of sitting in my place for
months and months and months I've had
these for years and just carry them from
place to place the place we live in a
condo honestly it's a pretty big condo
and it's basically the right size for us
no but but just this box is taking that
too much space in our condo in so okay
we gotta find that we got kind of home
so why did was I posted on kijiji and I
said targets for free free cards but
tell me why you're interested in them
and give me your story I hope well we'll
pick who gets it so Nina and I are going
to now pick the winner of who gets the
cards ok so here are the entries so I
said give me a story tell me why not the
first one from Jane egg hello thanks for
offering these up for others I would
want them because I love collecting all
sorts of things on with sports
memorabilia and I keep them in very good
condition and i just love collecting any
who have a good day that's ok that's
average I don't
like serious fashion and i won t dot T
dothis Toronto I married a feeling he
got 50 and city recently started getting
back into sports cars because I love
sports but I gave all my childhood cards
away to friends I would love to take
over your collection and keep growing
let me know they're still looking for a
good home that wouldn't feel a little a
little little better you're getting his
teeth off no no like I feel bad for the
guy like he gave all those cards away he
gave away he didn't have to yeah but he
getting away as a kid maybe his mom
forced him to know he did say he gave
all his childhood cards away to friends
doesn't mean that you give away when he
was a kid leaving his wife forced them
to moving on to the next one JAY Santa I
you what the heck of that who still make
if I show me again hi Oh still have the
card oh yeah I do you saw the card i
lost all mine in a fire so it'd mean the
world to me to get some to start
collecting agent like oh god cuz thing
again oh my god the typos are out of
control on this one but i feel like with
this guy but he lost those cars on fire
we think you need a buyer or they gave
it away to my friends the guy who whose
wife forced to leave rid of the tags
fire but the grammar is just how to
control on this okay fine hi I will take
them can pick up on monday Wow listen
Roger be I'm not feeling this answer
okay next do you still have a hockey
card sponsor yeah no sponsor that is not
an emotion
peel next rmc I'm interested in some
cards for son if they're free I give you
my address and you can mail them to me I
don't think so you're picking these up
friend that we might appreciate it I
mean it's ready son so that's like that
if he's but nail them well i'm not
paying the mail these are free hockey
cards son hello my name is steph and i
am interested in your car question for
my fiancee [ __ ] his entire life Jamie
seems to have had two aspirations to
play hockey and be a dad you plays
hockey still though not at the level he
wants hope and avidly follows just about
every team in the NHL to make it better
Jamie will get his second hope and
become a dad in April so happy story
Stephanie my sister's name is dead your
niece's name instead it's my knees too
late yeah that works we are getting
married in December and have been
looking for a special gift for Jenny
something that had sentimental value to
him and he would be able to hold on to
hockey cards had even occur to me until
now but they would be perfect to frame a
couple or hold into a book he would have
a little something of the hockey and
players who grew up with on top of that
I know if he's hoping our kids will love
hockey too and he would absolutely share
those memories with them he saved all of
his matchbox cars from his childhood
when he found them at his mom's last
year for when we have kids I think it's
a secret but he's pretty sentimental I'd
love to be able to give all that two-g
me one way or another I doubt it
wouldn't matter much who the players
were he knows everyone if you could help
me with this I'd really appreciate your
generosity yet not i want to thank you
to some fantastic inspiration warm
regards steffen it's pretty good I'm
feeling it yeah but this is the baseball
card please our heart oh these are happy
yeah mostly heartier ok yeah I think
it's really nice when your wife does
good things for you
i think i can do good things for you I
don't know what I'm talking about here I
know I feel there's something there then
I feel like it's nice to surprise your
husband with a gift like this and I
feeling like stuff is in the stephanie
is in the lead so far what do you feel
like I think it's a well if fiance but
they're gonna get married in December it
was further wedding I think if I think
it's a nice it's a heartwarming story oh
that's the last one we're done okay I'm
going with Stephanie the fiancee because
I love love what do you think do we love
love okay Stephanie winner so lesson for
entrepreneurs number one get rid of
stuff that is taking up spots in your
tiny condo and stop moving things and
one house to another to another if
you're not really driving lesson to do
nice things for your fiance or husband
and wife or girlfriend whoa yeah
girlfriend I number three love love love
this kid but love that's it we're done
gang parts new new new home new club no
we're not getting the cards yeah new
home for the cards that's it yeah more
space for me more space for you yeah
what no it means more like peace of mind
for me but there's less tired okay
that's it believe subscribe comment like
by if you want more believe energy
running through your veins sign up for
the newsletter below it's free you're
gonna love it hi i'm jason j reyez
fonseka of Ra's online com and i want to
say Evan Carmichael's newsletter is
consistent fun inspiring it's the only
newsletter i prioritize and look forward
to period